ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي في فلسطين اعمال
مستوطنين اسرائيليين احرقوا امام قوات
الاحتلال ممتلكات فلسطينيه وصفهم
بالارهابيين من ناحيتها انسحبت المانيا من
بيان مؤيد لاسرائيل بسبب سياسه تل ابيب
الاستيطانيه وكان الامين العام للامم
المتحده قد ندد باعتداءات المستوطنين
الذين وصفتهم واشنطن بالمتطرفين وطالبت
اسرائيل بمحاسبتهم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله توالي
الادانات الدوليه لاعتداءات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على الفلسطينيين واتهام
حكومه نتنياهو بالتواطؤ معهم وتوفير
الحمايه لهم اثناء تنفيذها ما هي الخطوات
العمليه التي يمكن ان تترتب على هذه
الادانات وما امكانيه اقدام المجتمع
الدولي على توفير الياته حمايه
للفلسطينيين من اعتداءات المستوطنين ووقف
التوسع الاستيطاني وما امكانيه توفير هذه
الادانات ارضيه لقبول دولي لمحاولات
الفلسطينيين دفاعا انفسهم امام اعتداءات
مستوطنين وما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه
لحمايه شعبها من هذه الاعتداءات
[موسيقى]
في سياق قلق دولي من اعتداءات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على الفلسطينيين ومنازلهم
وممتلكاتهم في الضفه الغربيه بمباركه قوات
الاحتلال وعلى مرء ومسمع منها وصف ممثل
الاتحاد الاوروبي في فلسطين المستوطنين
الذين نفذوا تلك الاعتداءات بالارهابيين
واتهم المسؤول الاوروبي في تصريحات
للجزيره اثناء تفقد دبلوماسيين اوروبيين
اثار تلك الاعتداءات اتهم السلطات
الاسرائيليه بالتواطئ مع المعتدين وتوفير
الحمايه لهم موقف يضاف الى مواقف دوليه
سابقه دانت تلك الاعتداءات من بينها
انسحاب المانيا من بيان مؤيد لاسرائيل
بسبب سياسه تل ابيب الاستيطانيه وادانه
الامين العام للامم المتحده لهذه
الاعتداءات وتجاوز واشنطن مرحله الادانه
لتصف المعتدين بانهم متطرفون تجب محاسبتهم
وتعويض المتضررين جراء افعالهم
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه من جنيف معنى
الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذو العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جنيف ومن واشنطن معنا
الدكتور تشارلز دان الدبلوماسي الامريكي
السابق في اسرائيل مرحبا بكم جميعا سنبدا
معك حسني عبيدي اذا ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي
يصف المستوطنين بالارهابيين ويقول ان هناك
تواطؤا بينهم وبين قوات الاحتلال في هذه
الهجمات التي نفذوها على المواطنين
الفلسطينيين ما قوه هذا الموقف باعتقادك
يعني هي قوه رمزيه لكن قوه لا يستهان بها
باعتبار لاول مره هناك تناهم بين العديد
من التصريحات سواء لممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي
في فلسطين كذلك كانت هناك زياره لبعض
البرلمانيين
وتقارير وصلت الى اصلا للاتحاد الاوروبي
من سفراء دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الموجودين
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
يعني هذا التناغم او لنقل هذه النافذه
الجديده اني بدات خاصه منذ وصول هذه
الحكومه اليمنيه جدا والتي هي معتقده داخل
البرلمان الاوروبي وحتى كذلك الاوروبيا
وكذلك نسبه العنف
التي وصلت الى درجات يعني قياسيه مع
الاعتداءات المتكرره بالاضافه كذلك الى
عمليات ضم اراضي فلسطينيه جديده هي التي
ادت
للمؤثره الاوروبي لهذا التقرير هي كذلك
مهمه لانها في النهايه تتلاقى مع العديد
من التصريحات الاخرى التي جاءت من قبل
ممثلي
الامور المتحده خاصه مقررين
مجلس حقوق الانسان وبالتالي يمكن القول
بانه لاول مره هناك يعني نوع من عدم
القبول الاوروبي للممارسات الاسرائيليه
التي مره اخرى بدات خاصه منذ وصول حكومه
يمينيه متطرفه جدا لاسرائيل وهو الامر
الذي ما زال غير مرغوب فيه بصفه كامله من
قبل الاوروبيين
هل هناك تطور في الموقف الامريكي بالنظر
الى حجم وفداحه ما قام به المستوطنون تجاه
الفلسطينيين
الامريكي طبعا هو موقف
ادانه اعمال العنف ومحاوله جعلك كل
الاطراف يخفف التصعيد وهذا هو العمل
الدبلوماسي الاعتيادي في مثلها ولكن يعتقد
ان محاولات المتحده تفكر ماذا تكون مع
الخطوه التاليه
فسيكون صعب بالنسبه لهم فانك فهم الجانب
يريدون وضع المزيد الضغط على حكومه
لايقاف المستوطنين
وايقاف التوسع المستوطنات عن ذلك وايضا من
جانب اخر خطر
غضب الكونغرس الامريكي وبالتالي فاعتقر
انه الولايات المتحده
تستزم بالسياستها
بالانتظار ومحاوله تخفيف الموضع والتخفيف
التصعيد بسرعه دون ان تطوير متحده ان تنفق
راس مال السياسي كثير لتخفيف الوضع
وتهدئته
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي من رام الله كيف
قيمت كل هذه المواقف الدوليه ما ورد على
لسان ومثل الاتحاد الاوروبي ما ورد على
لسان المقرر مقرر حقوق الانسان في الامم
المتحده وايضا الموقف الامريكي
نحن نرحب بكل المواقف التي ادانت هذا
العدوان وخاصه موقف ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي
الذي وصف المستوطنين المستعمرين
بالارهابيين ولكن نحن نريد اكثر من ذلك
انا كنت اتمنى ان تخرج السيده فندر لاين
مسؤوله الاتحاد الاوروبي وتدين ما تقوم به
العصابات الارهابيه كما قامت من قبل بمدح
اسرائيل كما تذكرون ولكن ما نحتاجه ليس
فقط ادانات واستنكارات هذه لا تعني شيئا
بالنسبه لحكومه نتنياهو
ما هو مطلوب فرض المقاطعه والعقوبات
الشامله على هذه الحكومه الفاشيه العنصريه
وعندما نقول نحن بحاجه الى حمايه نحن
بحاجه الى حمايه ليس فقط من المستوطنين
الارهابيين بل ايضا من حكومه الاحتلال
نفسها التي اطلقت 13 الف وحده استيانيه
خلال الاشهر السته الماضيه وبدات ببناء 15
مستعمره جديده منها اثنتان اقرتهما امس
وسمحت للمستوطنين بفتح سبع بؤر استطانيه
جديده على حكومه الاسرائيليه هي من ترعه
هؤلاء المستعمرين المستوطنين ولذلك يجب
فرض المقاطعه والعقوبات عليها وانا برايي
هذا النداء يجب ان يوجه اولا لجميع
الحكومات العربيه
والاسلاميه وللمجتمع الدولي باسره بدون
عقوبات ومقاطعه على اسرائيل لن يحدث تغيير
وبالنسبه للحمايه لا نريد ان يتكرر ان
تتكرر تجربه الحرم الابراهيمي عند مرتبه
المجزره الوحشيه على يد جولدشتاين
وهو من اصحاب بن جبير الذي كان جزء من هذه
الحركه الارهابيه في ذلك الوقت تحدثوا عن
حمايه ثم ارسلوا مراقبين وطردتهم اسرائيل
بعد ذلك ولم يحرك احد اصبعا ضد اسرائيل
المطلوب اليوم فرض عقوبات ومقاطعه على هذه
الحكومه الفاشيه وعلى هؤلاء الارهابيين
المستوطنين ويجب على الدول الاوروبيه براي
فورا وجميع دول العالم وخاصه الولايات
المتحده ان تصدر قرارات ضدها هؤلاء
المستعمرين وبعضهم يحمل جنسيات هذه الدول
طيب سنتحدث دكتور مصطفى لاحقا في هذه
الحلقه عن موضوع حمايه الفلسطينيين واليات
هذه الحمايه ولكن اعود اليك حسن عبيدي
وصفط الموقف الاوروبي بانه موقف رمزي ولكن
واضح ان هناك مخاوف في يعني يعبر عنها
ممثله الاتحاد الاوروبي ما هي هذه المخاوف
وكيف يجري التفكير في التصدي لامكانيه
التوسع ما حدث
يعني هناك صحيح تخوف كبير لان العديد من
الاوروبيين يقولون بانه لاول مره يمكن
القول بان هناك فرصه للاتحاد الاوروبي
لتجاوز دور فقط الدوره الممول وان يصل في
النهايه الى دور
المقاوله السياسي او الذي يقوم بملا
الفراغ الكبير الذي تركته اداره بيدا التي
في النهايه انسحبت يعني يمكن القول
الانسحاب كبير واصبحت تتدخل فقط في عمليات
الهدنه بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين لكن
هذا الطلب الاوروبي للاسف من قبل العديد
يجب ان نعترف من قبل العديد من الكتل
الحزبيه داخل البرلمان الاوروبي وداخل حتى
البرلمانات الدول الاوروبيه لا نجد له
مقابل من قبل الحكومات التنفيذيه اعطيك
اعطيك مؤشر واحد فقط يعني الاتحاد
الاوروبي صعب ان يتحرك كاتحاد الاوروبي
لانه في النهايه موقفه مرهون بموقف الدول
التي تشكل الاتحاد الاوروبي عندما رفعت
بعض الاحزاب السياسيه في البرلمان الفرنسي
مسوده للمطالبه فلسطين باعتراف بطلبه
فرنسا باعتراف بدوله فلسطين بدعم فلسطين
كذلك في التوجه لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه
وحتى البدء
التي تعتبر الجهاز القضائي للمحكمه كذلك
العقوبات على المنتجات التي تاتي من
اسرائيل كذلك توقيف ما يسمى بالشراكه
الاوروبيه الاسرائيليه التي وصلت الى
شراكه متقدمه جدا لا يعني لا ينقص في
نهائي اسرائيل الكثير حتى تصل زي مثل
علاقه دوله اوروبيه رفض حزب الرئيس ماكرون
ورفضت الاحزاب اليمنيه واحزاب وحتى لا حزب
الاشتراك رفض هذا الطلب فنعتقد ان هناك
اقتناع فعلا اوروبيا بانه لابد من فعل شيء
ما من التحرك في هذا الاتجاه وهو قضيه
العقوبات من سنه 2014 هناك اقتراح مهم
مطروح على اوروبا وهو معاقبه ومنع دخول
اوروبا كل المستوطنين الذين ثبتت عنهم
اعمال اعمال عنف هذا المصطلح الذي يستعمل
ضد الفلسطينيين او على اراضي غير مشروعه
لكن لم يطبق فهذه القضيه التي ما زمها
امام نحن الان وهناك تحرك بطيء جدا من قبل
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وكانها تنتظر قبل كل
شيء ان تتحرك الولايات المتحده التي ما
زالت تحتكر للاسف هذه القضيه
دعنا نستمع او قبل ان نكمل في هذا الحوار
الادانات الدوليه لتوسيع الاستيطان
واعتداءات المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين لا
تنعكس فيما يبدو على مواقف حكومه اليمين
المتطرف التي اكدت دعمها اقامه المستوطنين
سبع بؤر استيطانيه جديده في الضفه الغربيه
بل وطالبت بقتل المزيد من الفلسطينيين
المدافعين عن ارضهم
موقفي واضح ادعمكم بشكل كامل ومطلق واريد
اكثر من اقامه مستوطنه هنا الكثير من
المقترحات المطروحه لكن يجب ان تقام هنا
مستوطنه كامله ودائمه ليس هنا فقط بل في
كل التلال التي نراها من حولنا يجب ان
نستوطن في ارض اسرائيل الى جانب عمليه
عسكريه اسقاط العمارات تصفيه المخربين ليس
واحدا او اثنين بل عشرات ومئات اذا كان
ذلك ضروريا
استمعنا الى اتمار بن جفير وزير الامن في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يدعو الى المزيد من
الاستيطان والى قتل الفلسطينيين المخربين
كما وصفهم وبحقيقه الامر بينما هذه
الاداره الامريكيه تقول انها تعارض
الاستيطان تعارض الخطوات الاحاديه وصل
الاستيطان اليوم في فلسطين الاستيطان
الاسرائيلي الى مستويات قياسيه تجاوزت ما
كان يحدث في اداره ترامب التي كانت تدعم
هذه الخطوات بالتالي كيف ستتعامل اداره
بايدن مع هذا الواقع الجديد
ان اداره بايدن
لديها خيارات كثيره صعبه جدا اولها كيف
يمكن وبشكل واضح ان تبدين التصريحات التي
تطلقها بعض وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليته مؤثره ومتدعو وتشجع على
العنف وكم من الضغط لابد من بذله على
حكومه نتنياهو الرئيس بعد ما زال يعتبر
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو شريكا
وهذه ليست بحلول سهله لهذا الامر اداره
بايدن في الحقيقه لا تريد حقا ان تكون في
موقف ان تقوم مثل هذه الخيارات ولكن نصلح
نوضح بشكل متزايد بان هذه الاداره لا
تتجنب ذلك وما يمكن ان تقوم بالاداره
الامريكيه هو ان تبدا بالحديث بشكل اوضح
وبشكل علني حول ارائها حول اعمال العنف
الذي تحصل حاليا ليس فقط الدعوه للسلام او
الى التخفيف التصعيد بل توجيه اصابع
الاتهام لمن هو مسؤول عن هذه اعمال اعمال
العنف هذه
ودعوه حكومه اسرائيل لتحترام ذلك وهذا
اولا وثانيا لابد النظر في مساله ارسال
الاسلحه استخدام الاسلحه الامريكيه في
الغربيه في هجمات اقامه وتقوم بها القوات
الاسرائيلي خاصه كما حصلت في جنين هذا كل
هذه الخطوات سيكون لا تتطلب قرارا سياسيا
كبيرا من قبل اداره بايدن لانه كما قلت
هذا الواقع
ما نسمعه منذ جاء
تحديدا هل تعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه
بوارد النظر في الضغط على سلطات
الاسرائيليه في هذا الموضوع تحديدا موضوع
الاسلحه لان ما يجري استخدامه في
الاغتيالات يجري بسلاح امريكي ويستهدف
فلسطينيين من بينهم من يحمل الجنسيه
الامريكيه
بالتاكيد كلام صحيح تماما وبكل صراحه اقول
اعتقد ان اداره بايدن لن تميل الى القيام
بذلك لانك عدد كبير من اعضاء الكونغرس
وخاصه في مجلس النواب الذي فيه غالبيه
جمهوريه سينتقدون فعل ذلك لو لو هاجم
اسرائيل او انتقدها وهو لديه مايك في
مشاكل السياسيه حاليا ولا اعتقد انه السيف
ذلك ولكن هذا امر يمكن ان يتحدثوا فيه مع
الاسرائيلين بشكل خاص ليقول لهم ربما نحن
لن نكون مضطرين لا سنتحدث عن ذلك عمليه
علنا وندرسه الا عندما او سنفعل ذلك الا
اذا كنتم بالتقدير اعمالكم
تقوم بها حكومه
دكتور تشارلز دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي اذا
يعني اصبح واضحا الاتحاد الاوروبي قد يريد
بعض اعضائه ولكنه حاجز عن التصرف بسرعه
استمعت الى تحليل دكتور تشارلز دان للموقف
الامريكي ما هي الخيارات الفلسطينيه لكي
يحمل فلسطينيون انفسهم من ما يتوعد به
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون المزيد من الهجمات
والمزيد من الاستيطان
عندما يخرج فاشيك الذي رايتموه ويهدد بقتل
الاف الفلسطينيين لا تبقى ذريعه لاحد وانا
برايي من لا يقوم اليوم ولن من المجتمع
الدولي سواء كان الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي من لا يقوم بواجبه لردع
هؤلاء الارهابيين والمستوطنين سيصبح
مشاركا في الجريمه الولايات المتحده لو
ارادت تستطيع ان تجبر اسرائيل في عشر
دقائق على وقف كل هذه النشاطات
الاستيطانيه تستطيع ان تلزمها بلجم هؤلاء
المستوطنين لو ارادت ولكنها لا تريد
وتواصل استخدام سياسه المعايير المزدوجه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يستطيع ان يهدد بوقف
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بوقف استيراد
المنتجات المستوطنات بمقاطعه شامله على
الاقل المستوطنات بوقف الاتفاقيات العلميه
مع اسرائيل هناك كم هائل من الاجراءات
التي يستطيع ان يتخذونها بالمقارنه مع 11
الف عقوبه فرضوها على روسيا في اقل من
شهرين
لكن هل توجد اراده هذا هو السؤال اما
فلسطينيين فطبعا نحن يجب ان نعتمد على
انفسنا ونحمي شعبنا وانا اريد ان احيي كل
هؤلاء الشباب البواسل الابطال في ترمس عيا
حمو عشرات العائلات من الاحتراق الكامل
نتيجه رسالتهم وتصديهم للمستوطين وطبعا
سقط الشهيد عمر ولكن المطلوب اكثر من ذلك
الى جانب لجان الحمايه الشعبيه انا برايي
المطلوب من السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تعلن
بصراحه ووضوح تغيير عقيدتها الامنيه
والغاء التنسيق الامني وجعل جميع اعضاء
اجهزه الامن موجودين في كل هذه القرى الى
جانب الدكتور مصطفى مع المواطن الفلسطيني
الذي كان يتحدث في ترمس عيا لرئيس الحكومه
محمد شتيه عندما قال له اما صالحون ام
فليخرج العناصر التابعين للسلطه المسلحين
ويحموا الناس عمليا كيف ماذا تستطيع
السلطه ان تفعل اذا هكذا مطلب مثلا
تستطيع ان تستجيب لهذا المطلب بالتحديد
انا اريد ان اسمع اعلانا واضحا صريحا
قاطعا وهذا ما يطالب به الشعب الفلسطيني
بتغيير العقيده الامنيه والغاء كل اشكال
التنسيق الامني مع هؤلاء المحتلين
المجرمين ونريد ان نرى ابناء شعبنا ابناء
الاجهزه الامنيه مع شعبهم مع لجان الحمايه
واهم شيء الان مطلوب من السلطه الفلسطينيه
ومن كل القوى الفلسطينيه ان تتجه فورا
لتوحيد الصف الوطني في قياده وطنيه موحده
الخطر الذي نواجه رهيب خطر كبير جدا يشابه
الخطر الذي تعرضنا له عن 48 هؤلاء
المجرمين يريدوا ليس فقط نشر المستعمرات
وقتل الفلسطينيين يريد ان يمارسوا التطهير
العرقي مره اخرى ولذلك نحن الان جميعا
مطالبين بترسيخ هذه الوحده الوطنيه
والسلطه عليها واجبات كثيره يجب ان تنفذها
فورا وهذا هو مطلب الشعب الفلسطيني اما
على الصعيد العربي والدولي
اختصار صعيد العربي والدولي يجب باختصار
يجب مقاطعه هذه الحكومه يجب ان يسمع
نتنياهو لا تكفي اذانات ولا تكفي
استنكارات يجب ان يسمع من كل حكومه عربيه
واسلاميه انه سيقاطع وان حكومته ستقاطع
بالكامل حسن عبيد بدقيقه
كيف سيتصرف الاتحاد الاوروبي لحمايه
الفلسطينيين ازاءه وصف ممثله لاتحاد
الاوروبي ما قام بها المستوطنون
بالاعمال الارهابيه
يعني اعتقد معركه الراي العام مهمه جدا
لان البرلمان الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي
يتابع الراي العام الاوروبي واذا استطاعت
السلطه الفلسطينيه وكل الاطراف الطواقه
لحل عادل في النهايه ان تصل الى الى قرار
من متوجه الى محاكم دوليه في قضيه تمديد
ورفع قضايا بجريمه حرب باعتبار الامم
المتحده تعترضها جريمه حرب هذا مهم جدا
يعني بالنسبه للراي العام وبالنسبه كذلك
للاتحاد الاوروبي ومن الصعب في ظل هذا
التسابق العربي على التطبيع مع اسرائيل
فاعتقد هذه القضيه اصبحت يعني فعلا معقده
جدا بالنسبه للاوروبيه الول المتحده تطالب
اسرائيل بمحاسبه وكلنا يعلم ان اسرائيل لا
تحاسب كيف يجب على الفلسطينيين ان يتصرفوا
لحمايه انفسهم ماذا ستفعل هي لمنع
تكرار هذه الحوادث من جانب المستوطنين
لديها مناقشات مكثفه مع اسرائيل خلف
الكواليس لمحاوله حتى دعوه الاطراف الاخرى
بذلك مصر والاردن في قمه طارئه لتخفيف
التوتر والتصعيد لكن لا اعتقد الولايات
المتحده ستخرج عن مساله اداره
المتحده
وبالتالي الولايات المتحده تشعر بقلق
باننا ندخل الى انتفاظ عنيفه جديده
وبالتالي لابد ان نتوصل الى سياسات اكثر
فعاليه لوقف ذلك واخشى ان هذا هو ما توجه
اليه السياسي الامريكيه حاليا شكرا لك من
واشنطن الدكتور تشارلز دان الدبلوماسيه
الامريكي السابق في اسرائيل شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من جنيف الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جنيف وشكرا
للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه من رام الله
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]